hello and welcome to see you playing
north north hampshire began French
defense again French two or three games
ago create a fire ok I don't know that
move so some beef is on my agenda anyway
but I cannot do it at the moment I don't
know 92 this is a always very slow
developing setup which makes it a little
bit difficult actually to play in blitz
it's easier for Blackie to play can play
those all those typical moves and white
has to be able to careful but if it
works out you get lots of space like
here or a 5 maybe the night now is wrong
on e to shoot no that's a bad opening
resolve my development is not good
yeah I'm covering a three with a passive
move I don't know didn't feel right now
that's a pretty pretty substantial
opening disaster here and the fringe is
a problem i have not yet looked at it I
mean I'm trying out money for why not in
recent games because I'm working on on
on the Sicilian repertoire for white for
my students and the thing is people play
other stuff also not just a caesarean it
French is not so easy to handle
you need detailed knowledge about about
those openings okay here by check you
six-week edge right I'm taking this I
know the bad bishop but the weakness
only six is quite substantial here and
it's always the bishop always covered
this let's see I need to improve my
pieces here the night only to a
particular is pretty bad I wonder where
to put it oh he's answering this for me
to see three one two three probably one
looks a little bit neglected but I snow
will be one Queen a five
yeah but when do I go I don't really
have great great squares I can go here
nightly 49 f 2 I know it's probably
better they had an Oni to wear the night
was originally placed or what is he
doing a 92 or something 92 and then like
24 are some weird tactics anyway at
least I was reasonably quick here even
though i don't know the position that
well that's good yeah this is the thing
tactics my position is not very well
developed so take here Bishop c5 is
coming or here i will take take 95 so he
uses his better a better development
okay before I can take
t5 is a ticket we have it takes d4 I
think I can take take d5 that should be
ok I wonder is that some kind of tech
taken out before I still think I can
take I'll take it now in d5 the answer
will capture d4 but I have Bishop e3 in
this situation takes takes boom I'm not
sure this is good but now look be one is
interesting yeah I am this is
interesting now after you have something
moved the rook a for its not hanging
anymore and this um this gives me this
additional idea if you move the Queen I
might be able to take e5 like a queen to
a six or something no they need any Bush
planets the bishop I go into a five well
but now i can take here
or again some weird tactic I thought you
would just take a for now clock this one
year we came Quincy 3 is threatening the
check one
check and then then Queen to e1 or what
is the threat Bishop f4 I don't know so
if i take it but what is what's
happening here take it Andrew behind
morning b5 not not quite not quite
winning this but it's closed from p5 and
we just looked in one now get them check
trying to get the initiative now
oh wait I can actually check here clock
Andy seven it's a bit easier than fancy
tactics black [ __ ] and handles it was
a tricky position i think i was
certainly worse because some of the
somewhat leg ish development and now if
this was already kind of a yeah but that
didn't work out well the engine actually
wants to play b5 him this is an
interesting move just giving black this
giving blip de-spawn and basically
claiming that this is the better
situation than the one in the game and
that that can be true but really here i
can develop quite easily and i have this
and then the pawn doesn't count for all
that much at the moment so this is a
very good suggestion by the by the
computer I mean here here I'm worse
quite quite clearly might be three Queen
a fire fair there are many ways probably
for black to be better but I think what
he did was bad that's the strike yeah
I'm losing a porn I'm losing upon him
and today there's really no compensation
so but what he did also again it didn't
look bad yeah I think taking this
correct because I I need this pressure
on e6 yeah I didn't like my position
here with the engine was kind of okay
with what I did not with this oh we five
hi Missy five that would have been that
would have been very difficult to defend
I mean black is clearly better forget to
switch the zone sorry yeah black is
clearly better he of course
and it's also terrible to play yeah that
was that was his opportunity and he
bishops III was winning oh wow that was
a lucky win then there were a couple of
really i mean here hmm not even that
difficulty i didn't like my position but
I think here I defended reasonably well
and now I am flattered I could take pea
salad in there didn't there but I'm
getting somewhere here and we know it
cannot prevent that is also his seven
children yeah so there were some really
shaky moments there the opening result
was some was not good at all ok guys
thanks for watching